KATY
Who are you?
SHANG-CHI
I'm not who you think I am.
KEVIN FEIGE
We're going back to the very beginning
of the MCU.
We have a keystone event
and that event is
Tony Stark becoming Iron Man.
He's forced to build
these weapons for an organization,
and that organization
was the Ten Rings.
KEVIN FEIGE
And there was this wonderful character
that we really wanted to do
something with someday,
and that was Shang-Chi.
SIMU LIU
When they announced this movie,
I was really, really excited.
Kind of tongue-in-cheek,
I ended up tweeting Marvel,
"Hey, are we gonna talk or what?"
I'm very glad I did that.
AWKWAFINA
He's so intense as this character.
Shang-Chi was made for Simu,
and I could
feel his passion for it.
KEVIN FEIGE
The backstory of Shang is really unique,
in that he discovered
that his father was this evil overlord.
WENWU
The rings gave our family power.
SIMU LIU
He's brought back into his father's world
and has to deal with coming
face to face with him again,
and this is a much meaner
and more hardened father.
And then crazy stuff
happens after that. [Laughing]
WENWU
It's time for you to take your place
by my side.
SHANG-CHI
That's not gonna happen.
DESTIN DANIEL CRETTON
My heart is definitely in this project.
It feels in line with
everything I believe in,
and it is a crazy, wild, giant ride
that we are gonna go on.
KATY
Hold on, everybody!